Colombia is fascinating because it is  the most inefficient place I've ever  been in my entire life like you have to  ask for the bill minimum four times  before you get the bill oh yeah yeah  then they just go and then when you're  paying for something at the register the  thing to charge the card is never there  and they're never shocked about that  like you think you just leave one by the  register but you're like I'll just pay  with the card [ __ ]  like somebody could go to that country  and just organize it real quick and it  would be a [ __ ] super power yeah but  there's no urgency whatsoever the most  efficient people are the people trying  to sell you like Maracas on the streets  and I found out they're not even trying  to sell you Maracas the maracas are a  front to sell you Coke  I really got the cocaine  exactly but it was it was really cool we  had a great time